[Music]
[Applause]
counting and welcome back to the break
room everybody it's our daily show that
keeps you updated on the nerdy news you
need to know live from New Rockstar's
headquarters here uh today we've got so
much to talk about today we took
yesterday off and the news and the
topics just stacked up okay so bear with
us we of course we're diving deep Kevin
feige uh came out from his uh Hidden
Fortress did an interview with nuggets
aplenty guys we are going to read the
chemicals that's a publication you do
the interview
what did uh what did the review and
Nuggets of Plenty sound like
I just went from being words to just
sound effects
we're gonna read the tea leaves on all
the things that Kevin feige said uh what
that means about the future of the MCU
uh phase five Spider-Man sequels of
course uh we're gonna get into all of
that then we've got some quantumania
predictions we went through the entire
new Yorkshire staff before they
everybody's kind of seeing the movie at
different times but before anybody had
seen the movie they gave their
predictions we've compiled that video
we're going to play that later and hold
those people accountable they must pay
for what they've done
all people must atone All Gods Must Die
now some of us have already seen the
movie and know what those predictions uh
whether they're right or wrong some of
us still haven't
um and then uh we're gonna close out
with our nordvpn Movie Club we're
talking about 2009's at Zombieland I am
so excited to talk about Zombieland I
hadn't seen it in a few I mean I've
rewatched it since it's originally but I
haven't seen it in probably five six
years to be honest and I just forgot how
crazy that movie is and it's a lot of
fun to talk about yeah in certain ways I
think it really holds up and in other
ways it it has aged like a lot of Comedy
from that time period so I'm sure we'll
talk about it more yes a very
interesting movie that has had kind of a
a larger impact on on the culture and on
Films since then but anyways we're going
to talk about that later of course I
forgot to introduce my my co-host here
Tommy bechtels here great to be back
everyone I miss you all so much I I
really God there's so many people I need
to think Jessica Clemens is here
um I'll thank all those people now I
want to thank God they're nasty
Squier
it is uh it is a really big week here in
New York shores of course quantumania is
coming out we're super excited uh and
along with the launch of quantumania and
the breakdown that's getting released on
our Channel tomorrow we're launching a
new channel tomorrow the Deep dive I've
got I've got some early oh well there's
the the launch schedule sorry go keep
that beautiful launch schedule back up I
have I got Early Access I watch that
everything everywhere all at once video
uh yesterday it is an excellent video if
you liked that movie dislike that movie
haven't seen that movie uh you were
gonna love that video and I'm excited
for the other content as well oh God
what a thick schedule yes and then I I
even have
um we just got this hot off the press
some deep dive merch I'm gonna be
wearing this t-shirt tomorrow yeah water
bottles too too yes the water bottles
are cute this this guy is like a deep
diver we're calling him a vastronaut and
look at this little this little detail
on his helmet is the DVD uh resignated
driver yeah we're really excited for
that tomorrow we'll be watching Eric's
uh live stream breakdown and there we go
party and then we're gonna have a big
launch party uh maybe you'll see some
social media posts from that I'll
probably be live streaming on the gram
on your own tomorrow night until the
party oh yeah this is a little treat to
my deep divers yeah from the beer from
the beer cooler yeah
um from the from the back of a cop car
Brandon send bail money
hey let's get into our main topic here
today uh on Tuesday Entertainment Weekly
published an in-depth interview with
Kevin feige uh he anytime Marvel movie
comes out he kind of does a little press
as promotion for that uh he was talking
about the kickoff of phase five which
quantumania is is kind of launching uh
and we wanted to talk about some of the
big things he mentioned that he was
asked about that he answered so he got
asked about the next Spider-Man movie no
way home one of the five biggest films
of all time crazy seems like you would
want to capitalize on that obviously
we're going to have more Spider-Man
movies in our future so when asked about
that he very slowly dropped that
Spider-Man 4 is being worked on
he said all I will say is that we have
the story we have big ideas for that and
our writers are just putting pen to
paper now
you know how I feel this is my this is
my analogy Sony is Marty Genetti Disney
is Sean Michaels and they just got to
kick him through the barbershop window
and take that franchise from him it's
just like are you saying Sony is what's
holding back more Spider-Man movies no
I'm saying that's what's making like if
we could just let Marvel fly with
Spider-Man without being inhibited by
Pascal and her gangsters
uh that's my opinion personally I just
think we should have Spider-Man and
everything he's the best he's like he's
like you know Spider-Man Wolverine are
probably the two most popular Marvel
characters yeah yeah probably of all
time I mean yeah certain characters get
huge for for brief periods of time with
great comic book runs but I just you
know I want to just see that guy
slinging webs everywhere of course we
would all
want more Spider-Man rather than less
Spider-Man now if they're starting on
the script now those movies obviously
take a long time to make very intensive
they're huge giant budgets a lot of the
writing has to be kind of interspersed
with notes from other from from Marvel
Studios because they're like well we
have to include this little element
that's going to pay off and there's
always negotiations you can use this
Marvel character but you can't use this
one you can have Nick Fury you can have
whoever Kobe smolders sure but not but
we're not getting a smoldering Kobe
well now so what do we think if they're
just starting to write now and he's
that's what he's saying they might have
been writing it all of last year we
don't know
um do we think we see a Spider-Man movie
2024. 20 25 if they hurry I think is
what our uh do they want to compete our
man Drew out of their Drew side oh
that's a good question yeah so we're
getting in part we'll be in 2024. right
we get the first half of that this year
in the second half next year well that's
a good question is that across the
spider-verse yes now John when did the
last across the spider verse or into the
spider-verse come out in court in
relation to a live-action Spider-Man
okay so they were in separate years so
yeah I have a question we're not so sure
that these movies have they're not going
to tie into the Marvels I just don't
think they want to compete with each
other well I I hear you on that and and
certainly but Sony's trying to put out a
lot more movies right they got their
Cravens their their whatever now they're
gonna have Amazon series like so I feel
like they both would lose money and
Merchandising if they both came out with
Spider-Man movies at the same time
because all the Spider-Man from across
the spider verse will send out all their
shipment of like dolls and then
we'll just get a new Peter Parker's food
but I think it's like uh you're just
putting them two against each other you
don't want them both to fail you want
them both to succeed so maybe have one
come out a little bit later than the
other yeah and maybe maybe it's like a
May December Gap or something like that
which if that's the case yeah again I I
would guess this is maybe like a 2020
Summer 2025 right I also wonder if we'll
see Spider-Man in another movie before
yeah we have to right Secret Wars
uh
line up there yeah so we got time
um
Peter Parker Peter Parker can pop into a
Fantastic Four movie right now that's
where I could see him you know he has
frequently New York City
Parker pop into Pizza Papa okay hey
pizza Papa Pizza Papa gets paid uh now
we know I think the the writer that has
been announced for the next Spider-Man
we believe is Chris McKenna yeah
has not been announced that's the rumor
Eric Summers Chris McKenna Chris McKenna
a former Community writer and has been a
part of the writing teams for a lot of
the big Marvel movies in the last 10
years kind of part of the brain trust
there uh maybe the writers from the
first Trilogy of uh
um uh Tom Holland films anyways uh
obviously
Peter Parker Spider-Man
uh one of the biggest characters they it
must be important and it's it's
interesting that of course in all the
Marvel slates that have been released at
Comic-Con and whatever there is no
Spider-Man movie slated there but we're
getting something before 2026. yeah the
phase six is still can you show me it
I think that's it
put a pin in that Tommy we're going to
come back to that uh okay and then he
was asked him if he was asked about the
the Disney kind of the Disney Plus shows
their timeline and his quote was we want
Marvel Studios and the MCU projects to
really stand out and stand above uh so
people will see that as we get further
into phase five and six uh the pace at
which we're putting out the Disney Plus
shows will change we want to do shows
that can only be shows like a Loki are
we thinking like a Loki that's a cryptic
sentence I think like we could come back
to that was supposed to know how phase
four went is this like is this their uh
praise and polish they just were like
this is what we did in phase four this
is what we want to do differently for
phase five that didn't work in phase
four that's how I'm reading this and I
don't know that might not be the case
but it or it could be that uh iger's
back right wow so that's a big one right
and I think the two big factors right
now are I think some people not every
buddy not necessarily us some people
were a little disappointed with some of
the Disney plus series because their
objective in this last round last year
was to launch new characters right so
it's inherently rather than showing us
characters that we know and love like
your low-keys like your Wanda's like
your Falcon Winter Soldiers if we're
getting a Moon Knight a Miss Marvel a
She-Hulk you know maybe that'll be a
little bit more hit and miss that's a
harder job to do to try to launch these
new characters and if you're saying
which which ones could only be shows and
which ones could be movies I'd say at
the top of my head both Ms Marvel and
Moon Knight could have been a movie yeah
I mean maybe not as good but like you
could have introduced those characters
and told that story over over whatever
100 the origin story template is a tried
and true one in films 130 minutes on
either of them especially with when you
have a character like She-Hulk that is
or or Moon Knight it's heavily CGI right
like budget becomes an issue and we know
that Disney right like is uh that's why
they brought pilot Bob Iger back Disney
plus is like not making as much money as
they would like they might be scaling
back because honestly Marvel fans if you
knew that you were getting two and a
half Marvel shows a year on Disney Plus
instead of four would you unsubscribe
uh we know Tommy's just there for the
cricket uh but so to to get down to the
fine
print on it right feige was asked uh so
spacing them out or putting out fewer
shows a year is that what you're
thinking and he responded both
it's basing them out and putting out
fewer which those two things are linked
right if they're more spaced out then
we'll be right probably fewer so you
know there was at one point and we're
going to come back to this uh because
there was a Hollywood Reporter article
that just came out today at one point in
2023 we were gonna get just for Marvel
secret Invasion yeah ironheart Echo
uh Loki season two and Covenant chaos
might have snuck in at the end we were
potentially gonna get all our parts of
Five series I wanted um that's so sad I
still want it I loved it when they had a
million shows at once yes I mean New
Bright Stars loves it because that stuff
I like I like the white knuckling we do
in the mornings where there's no news or
shows but uh this morning a Hollywood
Reporter article said that as of now
secret Invasion and Loki are the only
guaranteed releases this year uh Echo
ironheart and coven of chaos have
possibly been delayed and there's been a
rumor for a while that echo which has
already been shot might be delayed I we
know that like uh ironheart has already
been shot or most of it has been shot uh
so this is kind of the first
confirmation we've gotten that those
things might be delayed do you think
they're delayed for storytelling I'm
sorry Jessica no cool no you go no do
you think they're delayed for
storytelling purposes either of you
question for both of you like they gotta
put out some of these movies first
that's what I was kind of gonna say I
think they already shot a lot of secret
Invasion right I think they're probably
secondly
um because you've been on the show a lot
have we already talked about we've
talked about Thunderbolt Ross right and
how he's projected to be like the
president yes so in secret Invasion I
talked about this in one of my uh
wakanda forever breakdowns that they
purposely on the ticker say president
ritzen and so it's like I think secret
Invasion has to be linked to wakanda
forever so they're like we need to push
this out as soon as possible so people
aren't confused at why Thunderbolt Ross
is the new president when we said it was
someone else's be a scroll that's what a
scroll in the Scrabble office it's Ritz
and didson
um Sean distant oh wait no it's Justin
well and also when you think about
secret Invasion and Loki those are those
movie stars are in that right you got
you got Don Cheadle Samuel Jackson and
one you got obviously Tom Hiddleston and
the other those are known characters
from the film Universe
um whereas Echo is built is a spin-off
of uh Hawkeye right following that
character iron heart kind of a spin-off
of wakanda forever following the Riri
Williams character and so you know
there's just like those are still kind
of like almost origin stories from new
new characters now they've already shot
those maybe this is also like a backlog
of like they've got to pour a lot of
money into the special effects and
everything like that that stuff is
cheaper when you spread it out and
you're not trying to do five things at
once I I think it has
a hang there's something so big in
secret Invasion that connects more than
these other properties that it's
yeah that's a good point it probably
ripples too many things squirrels are
big deals
yeah oh scroll watch uh that uh
Hollywood Reporter uh a company Insider
at Marvel said that there's going to be
a level of rigor on Marvel and across
the entire company I think that's
speaking to Disney uh one company
Insider said numbers matter now and
costs are going to be outlined and
enforced right and it kind of Bob said
hey
let's uh tighten up those pocketbooks
right because when they were launching
Disney plus it was like Hey we've got to
throw some big shows out there so people
sign up for this service Mandalorian you
know
um Hawkeye on division right like they
speak hero six okay yeah I was like how
much of that is Marvel's fault you know
I mean yeah we got a lot of big
properties and a lot of CGI needed but
it's not all Marvel's doing yeah all
right Star Wars is still there yeah and
those shows are more often than not
awesome right yeah um and lastly feige
mentioned experimenting with more
self-contained episodic shows
specifically with Daredevil as opposed
to shows that could be described as
eight hour movies and they're not even
that these episodes are 33 minutes long
with credits they're like four hour
movies which is just about a half an
hour more than any game I don't mean to
be like yeah but but then also a that
makes you think oh Daredevil might be uh
you know more
um cereal yeah right like uh or or like
a kind of a case of the week yeah right
a little bit more like self-contained
doesn't need to be like one Big Arc for
the season I think Daredevil that came
across in the Netflix series where it
genuinely I will give the Netflix series
their due worth making the shows feel
like TV series and I feel like Disney
pluses uh shows haven't really felt like
a TV series and maybe there's a
different writing tactic to like where
you hit the climax at but Daredevil
itself is already perfectly written for
like this is gonna be a show and it's
gonna feel like a show it's gonna look
like a show it's not gonna be like
really long movie see I I don't disagree
but I do think that Loki specifically to
me felt
like a episodic to episodic show like I
know it was telling one story but enough
there was very few episodes that you
could be described as like transition
episodes like I felt like something
happened in every single episode that
was like oh this is the point of this
episode it's introducing me yeah they
definitely felt like a Haver many
hour-long movie yeah right like that was
telling kind of one story it wasn't like
a different b-pods or something like
that uh and then finally or not finally
we've got a couple more things Kevin
feige was asked about mutants he's
always asked about mutants of course the
second Disney but Fox they were like
when are we getting more X-Men movies uh
and whose quote is saying the question
is how to do it and when to do it and
that's something we've been working on
for years now we know oh they've got a
plan yeah he's saying yeah right uh it's
not just like that's something we want
to work on it's like nope we know how to
do it and when to do it you haven't told
us yet but hey that's something we can
look forward to learning yeah and I you
know maybe some of us will become
mutants in them I've been rolling around
in toxic waste for years hoping for
something to happen in time but
something has happened and I've got
weeks to live wait what
why would you say that live here
because I want
haven't been on the show lately the
toxic waste
like he was asked about
um of course we've got Quantum any
coming out this week uh the next movie
is Guardians of Galaxy vol 3 and the
movie right after that late summer the
Marvels he's asked about that and he
said picking up directly after the end
of Captain Marvel one uh not in Timeline
but in story because obviously that was
in the 90s and there's been a lot of
movies in the timeline since then so it
so keep going read it and you're gonna
ask the questions I'm sorry we also do
that in our upcoming Disney plus series
secret Invasion and those are two very
different follow-ups to that movie comic
fans will recognize elements of the cree
scroll War
so was he saying so yeah yeah so the
first movie takes place in the 90s so
are we uh
avoiding what happened at the end of
Miss Marvel where she pops up no I think
he's saying it like continues the story
from that 90s song but like not the
timeline right like yeah we're gonna be
in present day
uh off Mike John loves to shout things
out uh yeah he's speaking to
um he was saying it's like immensely
powerful seeing Carol Monica and Kamala
together in frame like The Avengers shot
right when those three characters are
gonna get team up uh hence the marvels
of the title right uh he said Kamala
steals the show wow shots fired she does
shots fired
I could see it um with Kamala being like
just so like happy and Jazz to be seeing
her favorite superhero yeah again I
pitched it I think they're gonna be mad
at each other Monica and um Carol
Danvers are gonna hate each other and
that Kamal is just going to be there to
be the glue to be like you guys we don't
need to fight we're superheroes yeah uh
we're except we're really excited for
that and hey that trailer maybe now once
quantumania is out yeah you could open
up the door to get that trailer
everything we've heard is that that
trailer the footage that has been shown
is incredible I need it um other other
films projects uh fight you talked about
of course Captain America New World
Order is coming up not too far away next
year uh with Harrison Ford as
Thunderbolt Ross president of the United
States now is that original
uh NWO black and white or is that wolf
pack end up too sweet baby because you
don't turn your back on the Wolfpack
apparently that film starts shooting
next month for Anthony Mackey so insane
not insane I just think it's wild to
have Harrison Ford step into the MCU
immediately be president
immediately put it off that's just like
a pad just like in the regular United
States they have they had to wait till
he was in his 80s that's where he could
be the person hey yo
okay that starts shooting next month uh
blade starts filming in 10 weeks
I'll believe it
Shadow they're like 10 more weeks till
played y'all are playing with my man
they tease us with that last November
and then I got called off when there was
kind of some falling out we're gonna try
to pull this out the same time we I
don't know how far they're gonna keep
pushing blade but do you think it might
come out around the same time as like
Swamp Thing
uh maybe maybe they'll not only shoot
start shooting in 10 weeks the film
maybe they'll just take an extra couple
days and give us a Halloween
presentation yeah better I'm tired of
waiting
um play it'll make a kale smoothie out
of Swamp Thing you think you think you
think blanket Beats one thing I don't
know maybe you know he's good at
dispatching demons and uh Supernatural
forces uh he also mentioned that in the
Thunderbolts Bucky Barnes is the de
facto leader of that team he said they
are barely Heroes they wouldn't consider
themselves Heroes that's interesting in
that like um
people characters that could be you know
John Walker might have a little
something to say about yeah
the Menace I'm sorry I'm sorry I was
gonna say I think it's interesting that
they didn't offer it to Elena but I feel
like there's going to be something in
there where they're like yeah we did
offer to Elena she said no immediately
because she has to work with her dad I
yeah I I almost wonder though it's like
it makes the most sense for Bucky Barnes
to be the leader of that team he is
actually the oldest
minority doesn't count here but I also
think Val is probably
his like secret like if she's still the
director she was she the director of CIA
right now if she's pretending to be the
director of the CIA or is the director
CA then she's probably running the
Thunderbolt secretly yeah right she
can't be the public
it will mimic like uh The Suicide Squad
with Waller it'll be like a task team
that no one knows about yeah that's a
great point and so he's kind of the uh
Idris Elba figure and the saddest part
too is that like Bucky is like he last
we saw him in Falcon and Winter Soldier
he's he's uh it's like cathartic he's
very uh he's finally coming full circle
with himself in his mental health so
it's like he's easier to work with than
probably the Russian uh what's his name
is
but Stephen Herbert doesn't have to do
that accent too much yeah you know what
I mean that's hard work
be the leader
like his Arc yeah Bucky since since
we've seen him and especially in Falcon
Winter Soldier right like he's like in
the best place yeah now right he's kind
of dealt with a lot of his demons he's
going on dates with shitty Small Talk he
told his neighbor he killed his son he's
good he's coming full circle he got rid
of his notebook actually I don't know if
he did he get rid of him the
Winter Soldier either way he he's coming
he's coming but and I think that's why
it's great that like so he needs a new
problem and that's this group of pains
in the asses yeah yeah he needs a new
challenge he's kind of fixed himself now
he's got to fix them is abomination in
the Thunderbolts
he's another guy though that has kind of
fixed himself
but he was holding that incel tournament
yeah for money he was willing to do the
inside tournament did you go to high
school with me um okay hey uh let's
let's get into some let's get into some
headlines hell yeah okay
those I know that was that was a
headline stretched out uh but we got
some other quick headlines we want to
jump on to uh Patrick Stewart bless his
heart uh continues to him because he did
I understand Michelle everybody should
say Patrick Stewart made Rest in
paradise he's not dead we just wanted to
be relaxed no he weirdly has never
worked more he's doing Picard he's got
everything going on uh he continues to
hint at the potential return for Charles
Xavier and Magneto too an interview with
Entertainment Tonight uh Stewart said
that Ian McKellen played Magneto of
course in the X-Men films I responded
well to Xavier's appearance in Doctor
Strange 2 saying he would have done
something like that himself Stuart then
said but we're not done sir Ian and
myself we've got plans wow oh again
octogenarian actors let's get them
it's like
stupid like they're screw it
would have been alive for 80 years I've
been in Hollywood so long and I run it
now guess what I'm gonna be the Joker
and they're like why you are I don't
know maybe also I mean for Patrick
Stewart Ian McKellen like like multiple
generations of fans yeah have grown up
with them yeah right like uh and so like
just throwing them into a project even
for cameos is just catnip for us right
um oh in uh speaking of Joker we got our
first look at Lady Gaga in the Joker
sequel I mean I love okay so the red
lipstick on her like nose to lip so he's
like making out with her but it looks
like the blunt maybe blood oh it could
have been they just fought because that
was like Joker ended with he the blood
kind of made his Joker uh paint right uh
so my picture makes me uncomfortable uh
there's maybe some Hepatitis B getting
transferred in their photo we don't know
but um we are so excited I can't wait I
think that movie doesn't come out until
next year Joker
gonna be a musical
is that confirmed yeah I think so I mean
they both are Academy Award nominated
for singing
um also I just I love I love Lady Gaga
yeah I love her and like she's so she's
so talented I'm so proud of how far
she's come but like her playing Harley
Quinn like a bronx like in prison and
Harley Quinn we know we know she can do
unhinged if she needs to oh easy she can
portray that energy so we're very
excited for that
um I'm kind of less exciting
uh DC news well that's exciting I was
gonna say what if she sings Bad Romance
but you keep oh I like that or uh the
shallows
they just run back to that Star is Born
no boy wrap it up dead ass it's like
reverse instead of like uh it's like oh
you know it's sort of an old musician
with a new musician it's an old Joker
recruiting why are you walking with that
murder toy did you kill that God oh okay
save it for a 10 mandatory funds yeah
um uh yeah unless happy DC news
Peacemaker season two has apparently
been postponed uh James Gunn has tweeted
that he is working on Superman Legacy in
the Waller series first before
Peacemaker returns so it's probably
pushing that out a few years Waller's
following the first season of
peacemakers so I mean you can't have
them both come out at the same time you
know what I heard Patrick Stewart's
gonna play Peacemaker where'd you hear
that yeah
um uh we've got a poster from
Mandalorian season three which is right
around the corner oh my God I'm so oh
look at that bad boy freaks assemble
that's what I call my wikileakers are
you excited uh no I don't know no you're
not a big star racer no I always think
that shit's for nerds I can't
get it of course we will be going deep
on middle morning season three we'll be
doing breakdowns we'll be doing an after
show we'll see breakdowns baby and Tommy
will be on uh we're very excited for
that
um oh and I should have mention if we're
gonna talk Star Wars uh due to some
kerfuffles and and uh Bojangles and uh
whoops the Doodles the bad batch reviews
for episodes 9-10 will be out next week
as a combo episode I'll take no further
questions nor discuss why they'll be
delayed at this time but you can just
imagine I've been tied up in the courts
thank you Tommy yes uh we've been
enjoying those when they come out uh
again let's so today maybe tomorrow this
weekend you're probably seeing him in
quantumania some of us here in new rock
stars are also going to see it this
weekend some of us because we're very
lucky we live in the Los Angeles area
and sometimes we get into like early
screenings some of us have already seen
it but before anybody at new Rockstar's
got to see the movie we had everybody
sit down and uh answer their predictions
put them on tape for the movie so that
afterwards we could go back and be like
who got it right who got it wrong or
whatever so now we've assembled all of
those uh pre-recorded predictions and
we're gonna roll footage now great
all right we're gonna make some final
predictions for Ant-Man that was
quantumania I'm seeing the movie in a
matter of hours just some final
questions that I should lock in some
final predictions for hi I'm Whitney I'm
gonna answer all your questions about
ants sorry I gotta think about this I
don't want to say anything stupid let's
hope I'm always wrong okay
we're good on everything okay who do I
think will die in quantumania I don't
want anyone to die but uh gentara is
definitely gonna die I don't think we're
gonna lose any main people well perhaps
no one these are Marvel movies they're
they don't often kill people off often
they'll just like blast them off the
side of the screen like it's Super Smash
Brothers I really want
this to be the death of
comes out of uh the quantum realm maybe
Jenna Van Dyne dies too but I think Hank
Pym dies no way no way he survives
Hank Pam morning until we join you uh
Hank Pym Dad okay thank him because
Michael Douglas he's been the MCU for a
while now and like he's probably just
like all right I kind of want to go but
also there's a chance that of this King
that we see in this movie could die but
a variant of him
um ends up being the king that we face I
mean King Dynasty or Secret Wars I've
said this a ton of times I think Cassie
Lang's going to die in quantumania and I
know yes Jessica Clemens the villain of
new rock stars wishing upon death upon
everyone in the MCU maybe Lord kriler I
think Bill Murray we know he likes to
make like Zombieland type cameos where
he just shows up and then dies I think a
Modoc I think Modoc might be a one and
done Darren cross will there be multiple
Kings I've said this before on many
shows on this channel there will be a
council of Kings at some point in this
movie oh you know there's got to be
multiple Kings there ain't just one Kang
in this movie though I do think the Kang
we see in this movie will be the big
Kang bad guy that runs all Kings uh
through Secret Wars
and the rest of the Multiverse Saga
there will 100 be at least more than one
king at some point in this movie like
you cannot start phase five of the MCU
and like Loki promises multiple Kings so
we're gonna see more than one cake in
this movie I am very confident in terms
of relevance to the plot I think it's
going to be more powerful if there's
just one Kang stuck in the quantum realm
one conqueror that they got to deal with
but I think we're going to see on screen
multiple kangs or hints at multiple
timelines where multiple kangs did their
stuff I don't think so I don't think so
and I might be wrong on this because a
lot of people agree that there will be
multiple kings that will see them and
unless we're seeing it in a flashback or
a post-credit scene I just don't think
we're gonna I think we're dealing with
our big bad right now and we're going to
focus on the big bad until the next film
yes I think that there's gonna be so
many kings it's going to be a Kang bang
yes of course there must be what cameos
will we get I think we might see hints
at other Avengers or other kangs or
people related to the king family tree
so we might see like a Reed Richards
Cameo Fantastic Four Cameo but I don't
think we'll see what actors playing him
ants I think that there's going to be
Ant cameos there's going to be bug
cameos Wong is legally obligated to Kim
you in all Marvel movies I gotta say
Wong we gotta see Wong right there's got
to be a Wong in this movie I think that
there's a big chance that we could see
um The Incredible Hulk has a a main
squeeze in the in the microverse I think
her name's gorilla I think also since
like you know they're really going to be
teeing up Loki season two in this uh in
this movie I think we might get a hint
towards someone in Loki now this doesn't
really count I guess because it's a
post-credit pitch that I have I need it
to be the leader I think even though
he's not announced Michael Pena yellow
Cameo well Modoc escape the quantum
realm he better that big head needs to
fly I do think Modoc will escape the
quantum realm uh we may not see him for
a few pictures after this one but uh
Morocco pop up again soon no he's gonna
die I changed my answer that's who dies
it's Modoc he doesn't he's already lived
he's already lived once you only live
once we're good yeah of course my guys
he's here for good in the MCU where it's
going to be a Modoc world uh I bet my
life on it I don't think so so I think
modoc's more likely to die than escape
the quantum realm I believe that this is
just the first
this I believe it's just the beginning
for bodak and the MCU because we have
um I feel like the intelligentia is
coming uh with uh the leader coming up
and like you know Dr Doom and all that's
coming I feel like the Modoc is going to
be a big
um player in the upcoming phase five and
six with Val absolutely 100 my pitch for
the post-credits scene is Modoc leaving
and then appearing at the college that
we last saw the leader and that's
starting their team up what will our
post-credits scene be I would love to
see a post-credits scene involving the
TVA I think it's Council of Kings like I
said I just if they're setting up King
Dynasty to me it makes the most sense
that there will be a council of Kings
post-credits scene at some point I want
it to be secret Invasion I want that to
be the post-credit because I thought we
were going to get a Super Bowl
commercial and we didn't so I hope that
it's secret Invasion I want it to be
secret Invasion really bad I think the
quays is secretly okay and I think you
might be either Mr Griffin or um Victor
Timely but Waze is gonna secretly find
his way out of the quantum realm and
he's going to be in charge of Kang
um the king tower that we see in Loki
I have no idea I think if we're gonna go
out on a limb if I'm just going to stick
to my guns here I think some allusion to
Loki or the Fantastic Four I think the
silly one will be a joke maybe a Baskin
Robbins based joke and what's your wild
card prediction my Wild Card prediction
is that there will be a in a very
serious moment in the big battle or
something like that
there will be a fart joke
huh I think that in this movie there's
actually going to be no ants it's gonna
be cicadas because they scream someone
in the main Pim Van Dyne Lang family is
going to be turned to the dark side by
Kane convinced by King and and turn on
their other teammates well I think that
Modoc is behind all of this I think that
Modoc is the one who contacted Cassie
the one who's talking to Cassie and the
one that sort of convinces King to bring
everyone down the quantum realm to be
revealed that Kang is actually working
for Val Val's in charge of everything
baby you can't stop her she's the top of
the food chain for the entire MCU I kind
of want Iron lad to show up so if iron
lad is the one that helped Cassie create
the device to send a signal into the
quantum realm that would be great miss
minutes is rensslayer's memory that's
trapped in a orange holographic form and
that's why Rensselaer doesn't remember
fully everything but like once
rinselayer can rejoin Miss minutes that
will be the Rensselaer that he remains
had a had a marriage with uh and uh and
that she's being tortured and separated
into these two halves her her memory
bank and then her her physical body uh
will that get reveal to guatemedia hell
no but I think that's just my Wild Card
prediction that Miss minutes will show
up in a scene and explain all this to us
all right those are my final predictions
for quantumania I don't think any of
them are going to be right but uh I
guess we'll see on the other side see on
the other side brother
nerves all right
and we've we've been asking in the chat
kind of uh running most of these
questions by you all uh what character
will die 41 saying uh Pim one of the
people so that is I mean it's a smart
bet you get the most for you know the
most bang for your buck there
Janet Hope or or hey oh that's a good
point I mean they're all in the Pim the
man is the alpha of the family and
therefore the king and Rule okay Tommy
the women are subscribed
the next the next highest a lot of
people thought nobody a lot of people
voted for nobody dies which I I like
your optimism who plays nobody in this
Hey yo uh I like how there's no the
Planet Nowhere and then there's the
person nobody
uh will will there be multiple kangs in
quantumania resounding 73 saying yes
yeah I mean oh yeah that's kind of part
of the dude's stick is that there's a
lot of him uh if we get a cameo who will
it be uh our man Wong coming in with a
little bit over a third uh and then
about a third of the people saying
somebody we've never seen now that's
that's a tough balance of strike like a
cameo from a new character kind of like
Hercules we got in uh 411 thunder right
like uh uh that can be a little tougher
for a movie to pull off but that's fun
uh what will our post-credit scene teas
uh 30 saying Kang Dynasty uh about 26
saying secret Invasion the next thing
and maybe a reason they're not delaying
secret invasions got to come out
sometime soon
um yeah and then there's a couple other
Super Chips we want to shout out Corey
kendrilli asking why Tommy's sitting on
that end of the table listen when we go
from four people to three people
everything's I don't want to do okay
shows too much of this
response no we could have done that
earlier but your vanity Tiffany Hoffman
saying do you think that Spider-Man is
done being an Avenger and ready to be a
Defender oh that's fun Tiff can I call
you Tiff that is very fun Tiffany I like
that idea uh fly ninja 808 saying uh do
you think that Spider-Man oh no that's
the same one find ninja saying phases
seven through nine will be the mutant
song that would be sick three phases
that's a lot of mutants maybe so much
comic book stuff yeah that they
especially done the Marvel way
especially by then they will have a nice
gap of time not only between obviously
the original X-Men trilogy but then all
of the first class Saga as well right
now if China would cleanse the palette
and you can kind of reboot all that
stuff hard Christian unpronounceable our
friend from Canada saying time for the
obligatory reminder to like And
subscribe this the stream thank you
thank you Chris doing the real work out
there and then the real tree I love your
uh design pattern uh I'm seeing
quantumania tonight I just wish I had
some merch my man's or women's you could
grab this shirt Quantum Thief featuring
a very fun uh Scott inspired graphic
there Quantum teeth as yeah as well as
someone said the quantum sheesh
Jessica's eyes just rolled back in her
head so hard uh as well as a bunch of
other cool quantumania inspired merch at
nerdriot.shop he's got that particle
rizz uh now I want to say something
before we move on
I think that there has been a real
blind spot and maybe the blind spot
isn't me because this has happened but
in the MCU when it comes to cameos now
these people many of these Avengers have
been famous for a decade yeah like in
the MCU like they've been famous in that
world how have we not had one of them
appear on the hundred thousand dollar
pyramid will Fortune celebrity edition
gets Sajak in the MCU have Hawkeye on
Celebrity Wheel of Fortune give me
you're telling me ant-man's not showing
up on Celebrity Deal or No Deal you
think Mandel's turning down that patreon
I mean I think that's it he does I think
that's like what we got kind of with
Miss Marvel's like little fan con and
then we kind of got uh the the Scott
having his book I want to have Shooters
though I want say Jack going Scott Lane
for some reason I think Marvel thinks
it's really hard to make things canon in
the MCU and so like that's why like what
is it it's like Conan O'Brien
technically now Megan is stallion but
they don't go Anderson Cooper they don't
go too far and it's like is it really
hard to actually get the rights to put
Jeopardy into the yeah probably you know
they probably lean on that's right
there's that one New York local TV
station that's an old Spider-Man movies
when I was doing they're not giving
Jeopardy away when I was doing the
She-Hulk breakdowns there was a lot of
news sources and there's actually an
incredible website that tracks all over
through the MCU and all TV every
fictional news program so you can see
the ones that have shown up and
everything and Spider-Man does have all
this yeah same guy uh yeah I I love that
uh yeah we'll keep an eye out
um it feels like She-Hulk might be a
good she could be a good candidate to
maybe do some more crossovers she was
appearing on the news a lot the exactly
She-Hulk yes please
it's easier for her she's so tall
when she's in Hook form very easy to
reach down I have been on Wheel of
Fortune I won 7 200 back in 2017. you
sure did that's true that's true give me
that money came in second place I did
not get to go to the final uh whatever
final Wheel of Fortune's hard I can't
guess that there was a mom from Iowa
slayed she crushed I I was very happy to
get out of there with with some money
though well she Crush could also be on
uh no no I don't want to make this a
Wheel of Fortune show but I know I'm
just kidding I thought she crushed was
on thrust hey yo I had to divest all my
shares of thrust oh no tell me right
before the big IPO yeah it was the big
pull out
after the initial
they pull out were very difficult for me
sorry
um okay speaking of dirty jokes let's
transition this is a perfect transition
all week long our sponsor our friends at
nordvpn have been helping us bring this
show the break room to you uh There's
the link up on screen it's also in this
video's description click and get your
own nordvpn uh you know protect yourself
from your ISP spying on you all kinds of
other stuff it's incredibly fast it's a
great service and for our purposes it
gives you this great ability to change
your location so you can use Netflix
libraries from other countries so that
you only got to subscribe to one Netflix
you can pretty much find any movie
because if it's not available on us
Netflix it's on UK Netflix or France or
South Korea or wherever Netflix we used
that to watch Zombieland yeah for a
little nordvpn geo-blocked Movie Club uh
we picked a Zombieland from 2009 because
with The Last of Us zombie movies are
kind of hot or the the zombie concepts
are hot right now did you see that they
don't want you to call them zombies and
The Last of Us the cordyceps not zombies
oh yeah
that's a great point and maybe it's
better to say post-apocalyptic movie
genre stuff right because they're both
firmly Set post-apocalypse uh and so we
watched that movie with the help of
nordvpn next time we're going to keep
doing these nordvpn movie clubs next
time if you haven't already signed up
sign up you can watch along with us but
if you did get a chance to watch
Zombieland this week or you've seen it
recently or you just like that movie
we're gonna dive into it a little bit
chat about things we liked uh things we
were surprised by in the re-watch yes
other other thoughts on it uh again
nordvpn easy to use just one click right
now uh if you click that link that's in
this video's description or it's on
screen right now you get an exclusive
nordvpn deal uh you get a huge discount
off your nordvpn plan and a bonus gift
it's completely risk-free with nordvpn's
30-day money-back guarantee thank you to
nordvpn for helping us bring the show to
you so
quick first thoughts
what what was your experience
re-watching Zombieland I uh forgot sorry
yeah I see you switched the camera
was like uh I forgot how actually I I've
watched this movie a ton of times yeah
between 2009 to now I love Zombieland I
love zombie movies it's one of my
favorites and I forgot how funny it is
when Bill Murray dies and how long he's
actually in there I thought as soon as
he appeared he got shot no he smokes
with them they reenact Ghostbusters they
hang out the whole idea was they were
gonna like put the wig back on do a
prank of a zombie on Jesse Eisenberg and
Jesse eisenberg's shotgun straight
straight
completely right in my opinion yes yes
yes
don't zombie prank somebody in a zombie
apocalypse because we are going to add
that to the uh rules for survival news
Zombieland uh yeah I forgot how hardcore
that movie was in terms of the flesh
eating element the opening five minutes
of that movie are just people chewing
other people and normally you gotta
subscribe monthly for that this is oh
wait
I actually was the editor-in-chief of
two monthly for a while before I was
fired and disgrace
oh yeah anyway I forgot yeah it is a
aggressive violent film it was I love it
I love it are you a friend of are you a
fan of Gore to that level no oh yeah but
but for some reason I remember you know
I'm not a I'm very scared man when it
comes to horror movies I saw Zombieland
opening weekend I was very excited for
it it's so funny it disarms you like you
can never stay shook by the zombies long
enough there's always something funny
happening and I don't know that opening
slo-mo sequence of all those montages
weddings and firehouses and other stuff
just being destroyed the zombie
apocalypse uh well some of them were oh
I'm so sorry I keep cutting you up no no
please I was like the beginning a lot of
them are the references to movie
classics yes uh and also uh because I
remember the intro has the stripper
zombie yes and I was like I would love
it also shows you how fast the people
turned because people were just at a
strip club in the zombies turn right and
uh
the little kid's birthday party where
all the little girls in slate turn yeah
and I think like I had never seen
Zombieland before I watched it this week
uh somehow it just that was a movie that
slipped through the cracks I was very
aware of it but I never got around to
watching it so yeah that struck me I was
saying tonally it's very interesting now
Reuben Fleischer who directed this movie
who's also directed both the Venom
movies the Uncharted movie a couple
other uh big flicks
um said he was inspired by Sean of the
Dead yeah you definitely see that that
combination of comedy and zombie
violence horror stuff right this maybe
leans a little bit more it's obviously
much more maybe graphic
fast zombies that's always the
difference Shawn of the Dead did classic
shambling dragging their legs zombies
that you're like if you just kind of
move fast and don't allow you know
yourself to get cornered you can get
away from these zombies yes these ones
were like the they've turned into
superhuman J Jaguar speed level zombies
that can just Leaf out and kill you from
anyway number one is cardio that's right
cardio I was gonna say like this movie
is also clearly now very different tone
but clearly very influenced before this
came out kind of the zombie genre was
kind of revitalized because this is
pre-walking dead yes Walking Dead
debuted in 2010 at the same time but
it's definitely post uh Zack Snyder was
rebooted Dawn of the Dead Right which
kind of like is credited with kind of
reigniting the interest in zombie movies
Ian was like oh yeah this is how graphic
you know hyper violence hyper stylized
zombie movies can be and had a similar
kind of like opening sequence right like
not not in the exact same style but like
kind of iconic with the great musical
score and everything I I think they
which I really liked with this zombie
movie which I think was what they were
doing I went to a q a with the guy that
did trick or treat and he spoke about
this about how like we we fell into a
hole of making these like nostalgic
movies that are great but we kept to a
tee of like this is a zombie movie This
Is A Vampire movie this is like a serial
killer movie and to be more grounded
with it and be like okay what if I push
as a normal kid that's like a recluse
and from college in Texas into a zombie
movie how would he react versus like a
survivalist yeah and I like that and him
becoming an uh his neurosis
being a key to his survival yeah yeah
and his and his and his like
shelteredness and his in his in his
desire to not be around other people
being the one thing that you kind of
need because you know human human needs
and emotions will will blind you and
you're like I just miss the like seeing
other people it's like well that's one
way to get eaten by a zombie in this
world where he is you have this guy
phobia of public bathrooms and that's
like I mean those are things I think
about all the time all of my phobias I
think would make me very difficult to
kill people I think I always check the
back of the car I always check on it
that's okay under all beds I check in
closets I sleep with a little NightLight
on I you know I keep a gun loaded gun in
my pocket oh no there's a great book
that people should recall how to survive
a zombie apocalypse oh yes and it's
perfect because they teach you Max bro
never to have yeah never to use a gun
just use a knife you don't have to
reload a knife but um I also I think
this movie speaks to everybody because
it's like oh if I have to poop all the
time where do I go how do I do it and
this movie happens all the time
speaking of poop I want to shout out
there's a prolonged kind of Cameo from
Mike White is the uh comedic actor who
gets attacked while he's on the toilet
and also works for the gas station and
gets con artist by Emma Stone yes he
wrote created uh both seasons of White
Lotus yes I was like he's also Ned
sneebly yeah uh fun to see him and Amber
Heard uh shows up in an early scene
she's the next door neighbor
yes
she is she looks very different but uh
clearly this movie was really well cast
there's also something this was a an
original Ip I guess this was a script
that had been floating around a little
bit it was originally going to be a TV
pilot okay they kind of that's why I
like the zombie kill of the week is they
hold over from it being an episodic TV
show
um but they kind of we were like oh this
works better as a movie they stretch it
out and obviously it was really well
cast like this is young Emma Stone
before she kind of totally blew up still
pretty young Jesse Eisenberg who hadn't
done as much uh obviously Woody
Harrelson was a known figure at that but
he is having a great time and when you
get him like really loving like just
like they're clearly letting him do
whatever the hell he wants like he's
making a lot of choices he's playing a
like complete scumbag who like gets off
on killing zombies it's so funny I will
say like one thing that struck me
watching this obviously like the kind of
fun comedic tone the Bill Murray Cameo
there's a lot of fun stuff in this but
like a big difference here in almost all
other zombie or post-apocalyptic content
including the last of us is like there's
very little dread yeah in this movie
yeah yeah right usually the takeaway
from The Walking Dead or any of the
George Romero zombie movies is like
you will get got yeah yeah and your
fellow man will probably end up that was
the one that was one of the new rules he
made like rule number 32 was like
um enjoy the little enjoy the little
things yeah and they take the time to
you know Smash Up a store or do
something goofy to find some Twinkies
you get very little of that in other
post-apocalyptic or zombie content
what's interesting again once you have a
survivalist you can do whatever you want
and if you have one survivalist in the
gang that loves guns that does all these
things you can be as loud as you want
yeah you can do whatever you want right
things I think my my favorite sequence I
know we're getting close to the end of
your favorite sequence is probably my
favorite one of my favorite zombie
sequences of all time It's when
um uh the the two girls are in on the
amusement park ride going up and down it
doesn't come with creative ways to keep
the zombies because that's like the time
the ride so they can figure out like
when they're gonna go up again they're
gonna stay up they drop back down and
just think about like being on that ride
for four hours alone would make some
people tap out they had to still fend
off zombies with the guns until they run
out of boats I I like it I'm a big
zombie land Mark I you know we don't
have to talk about the sequel ever uh I
like the sequel It's next on my to-do
list now I gotta watch the sequel double
tap well and it struck me away again
just the amount of joy that this movie
finds there's still some very scary
moments and tense moments or whatever
but overwhelmingly the vibe is like kind
of goofy comedy slap sticky whatever uh
it reminded me of there's not that many
of these moments in the last of us but
like the pun book yes you know what I
mean little moments between Joel and
Ellie where like a little break between
the devastation
dead where
uh uh what's his name thing ask Michelle
if she stole it and then he he she lies
and says no and then Rick tells him like
later on she did steal that protein
yeah just like it's it's nice as a as a
change of pace whether you're a fan of
the genre I think this movie is aimed at
people that maybe aren't even fans I
mean like me I'm not a zombie yeah
person but I became one for you know I
became a zombie you're a zombie is that
is that what the toxic waste did to you
you're turning into a zombie no no no
that's just uh cysts and
I've always said Tommy's one of the most
high functioning zombies I know oh yeah
thanks zombieism is a spectrum
all right guys I know we gotta we gotta
leave but I wanted to have a little
mandatory included on our in our break
room club uh we're only gonna put the
graphic once because I I just want to
power through these uh the the movie has
33 rules only like six are acknowledged
on screen uh We're not gonna talk about
the sequel which added rules so I added
some new rules and I thought you guys
could do them uh and read them with me
rule number 34 do not dress up like a
zombie if you don't want to get shot in
the header chat yeah amen easy and
that's an easy rule yeah rule number 35
maybe look for a house on an island I
mean I don't know the zombies
that's been done in some other movies I
mean that didn't help them in a quiet
place part two well how about up in a
mountain okay okay
rule number 36 pogo sticks may look like
fun but they are not good for getting
away from zombies I mean yeah easily
rule number 37 zombies do not care about
your nfts are you sure you maybe could
bore them to death I don't know uh rule
number 38 Tigers might seem like fun
pets but there are no Animal Control
Officers and zombies that is true so
just stay away from them that is true so
don't go to zoos that's right don't go
to zoos okay don't blow on kazoos rule
number 39 you can delete your dating
apps no it's over no it might not be I
mean if you meet a person that you're
interested in in Zombieland and they
won't F you they're never gonna I think
I think I would I would contest this
rule I think it's the opposite I think
you gotta swipe yes on every single
person and hope you get anywhere who's
always swiping yes zombie pause no
you're face down you're you're tindering
you're shivering your tinders okay so
sorry so sorry do you guys remember I
was uh very very single on Tinder at one
point in the summer during the pandemic
that Tinder did a zombie apocalypse
Tinder Edition where it would swipe your
story and you were in a zombie
apocalypse looking for someone
literally too loud okay rule number 40.
use your card across the head of zombies
stop Wasting Bullets good point rule
number 41 all zombies are technically in
ketosis so give them a compliment
they're all yeah and uh rule number 42
our final rule it is still not okay to
pick your nose in your car anyone alive
can still see you and it's embarrassing
is that a rule your car is not a force
field that makes people makes you
invisible if you're digging for gold in
the driver's seat or passenger sieges
we're looking at you just you're just uh
you just get tinted windows I think
that's my trick
um not that I've ever picked my nose uh
thank you Tommy I like those those are
pretty good additions uh thank you all
so much for watching we're gonna be back
tomorrow with a post quantumania episode
so tomorrow's episodes will include
spoilers if you're uh planning on seeing
quantumania Friday or Saturday or
something like that just come back and
watch tomorrow's break room later on in
the weekend or early next week yeah uh
Zach before we go I just want to very
quickly sorry there's the launch day
slate for deep dive as a reminder yeah
uh Eric and I we wanted to thank we were
guests at kybercon last weekend I've
been out all week so I haven't got a
chance to thank them I want to thank
mezzo and Van at kyber Cave Productions
they're a very fun YouTube channel they
talk a lot about Star Wars and
lightsaber specifically give them a like
and a subscribe if you can that's hybrid
cave Productions and thank you so much
for having us at kybercon we cannot wait
to return check about kyber K
Productions good people you may
recognize mezzo from the uh from the
chat yes so uh yeah thanks again sorry
just wanted to get that out there go
ahead and end the show Zach yeah hey
let's take it on home everybody have a
great rest of your day uh we'll see you
back here soon oh yeah Jessica already
has a video out on the Channel
ending explained for quantumania there's
a there's a post-credit video from Eric
and ending the explained video from
Jessica uh and of course a lot of really
good quantomania content coming your way
in the next few days so watch both those
videos
uh like And subscribe All That Jazz and
get ready to Deep dive baby splash
[Music]
thank you